people all throughout the grade not just
in five one all the way up to five three
they struggled with this shape okay so
let's try and unpack it and see what's
going on
read the question again right just to
refresh yourself like what are we trying
to find what's the um
what's the actual volume that they're
looking for okay how would you describe
this shape
it is cylindrical but it's not just a
cylinder is it
because it's um
it's been hollowed out
so i guess i'd call that like a tube or
a pipe that's the kind of thing we're
looking at right
so therefore when you're working out
this thing has been hollowed out okay
you want to work out the whole volume
right the whole volume and then you want
to take away
the inside part okay
subtract the inner volume
okay so this is my setup this is just me
interpreting the diagram and now how do
i calculate it okay
just off on the side here what is the
volume of a cylinder
how do we work it out
so you gotta get a shape like this right
okay
so for starters it's based on a circle
right so what's the area of this base
we just looked at it in the previous
question right
it's an area so it'll be pi r squared
right okay so there you go there's the
base
but you've got this height to deal with
right whatever that might be so you call
that h for height
so in order to get the volume all
together we're putting these two
together
pi r squared h okay now you didn't get
anything for just writing down the
formula you had to use it correctly as
i'll show you in a second but there was
an additional trick right do you have a
look at this
which of these numbers on the diagram
which of them is the height
now yeah it's sneaky the heights has
gone sideways right
so really it should be like this
at least that's the kind of perspective
that we're looking at okay but heights
can be sideways if you're measuring it
that way right
so if that's your height i've got six
in here
right
and then you've got pi
now you've got to work out what to put
in that other number there the radius
okay so i'll write it back so that you
can see the numbers
what's the whole
volume
oops
what's the radius
of the whole volume six nine hmm now
this is tricky isn't it right which one
is it okay now in fact i'm going to draw
part of it just so you can see what's
going on so
here's our shape
and i'm just trying to work out what's
happening here okay and on your diagram
you've been given this distance which is
three
yeah
and this distance which is also three
okay so now if i want the whole cylinder
right what i'm really after is this
distance right
so you have to add them you do have to
add them it's six which is quite off by
the scale that they're looking at right
the scale is really off so i should have
said not to scale on the diagram but
it's still clearly enabled okay
so therefore if i'm working out that
whole volume
six is my radius jab but don't the two
lines go like halfway into all the holes
okay so are you talking about this one
here yeah yeah okay so
if i put a line through there right that
should be the center of the circle yeah
okay so then the radius is from the
center all the way to the edge which is
six okay and that's for the outside one
okay so there you go i'm going to say
this is equal to
the whole volume first which is
pi
times the radius squared
times the height
so 600 okay yes which is well i think
that's going to be 216 but we'll get
that in a second okay
then i have to subtract something when
you're going to use exactly the same
principle to work out that inner volume
okay it's still pi r squared h
the height is still 6 because it's the
whole length of the tube right but this
time the radius is
well it's just the inside part which is
good
okay there you go right so that's quite
hard to get to that point to be able to
interpret that quickly basically you
could get that and go from there yep
oh okay so hold on i'm just going to put
down one more line of working just to
show you
um
you could also factorize this because
have a look it wasn't the question but
you guys know how to do this right how
many common factors can you see between
these two
pieces
i can see two what are they
pi
and six
very good okay so if you wanted to save
some time one second
you could have written this
that's really what's happening okay yeah
that's right
now let's evaluate it okay
if you went straight to your calculator
and punched this in
i'll just quickly do that's 36 minus 9
27
27 times 6 pi i think it was what was it
five hundred and something
time
there you go
now units again watch out it's a volume
so
seven meters is cubed it's very good
fantastic
so
two marks roughly speaking we're looking
for you to interpret it properly okay
one volume subtract another and then to
calculate it properly and evaluate it
okay sometimes you might have gone
straight up here but if your answer was
consistent down here even if it was
wrong
i might have been able to pay your mark
depending on how wrong it was okay